Jenna Dewan and her world of dance balls
beautiful Lopez are admitting they don't
always get it right on stage and they
have the dancing injuries to prove it
I'm chip like you did so much stuff on
stage and I feel like I have stage
angels because I do such crazy stuff on
stage I've fallen on my face at least
ten times one time I mean this I I fell
off the stage muscle janice like living
up there and I took what's up and I went
boom like down right into the front row
nice to know even the pros can have an
off day and that's exactly why as an
executive producer of the show
JLo is always willing to give
competitors a second chance if you
didn't make it to a certain point you
can come back for another season and
they are allowed to compete the bottom
line is you want to come and beat the
person you didn't beat last time well
the nature of competition is you you
don't win and you reassess you country
plan and you come back twelve acts are
left going into next week's cuts that's
when Sierra guest mentors and from this
sneak peak it looks like J Lo's work
hard philosophy is in full swing you're
just you know that's enough that's
enough to bring us into your hearts with
a million dollar grand prize on the line
we just hope no one's hair gets stepped
on
kind of like when Derek give JLo that
one time salsa dancer not just you okay
thank God yo when I dance what other
that's actually from your other show I
think you make us nervous they get
nervous I don't like you guys my big
tribute they like step on my feet they
pull a yeah amazing
[Music]